so part of Donald Trump's tantruming
like a child around the g20 summit had
to do with his cancelling his meeting
with Russian President Vladimir Putin
but then it turns out he actually had
the meeting anyway I'll explain the
sequence here and how it went down
Trump told reporters before arriving in
Argentina that he would probably be
meeting with Vladimir Putin okay then it
was announced he was actually not going
to meet with Putin because Russia did a
bad they didn't return a ship and
sailors to Ukraine after seizing them I
told you about that last week and it was
immediately clear that that's not the
real explanation because Trump said
absolutely nothing about that four days
but that Trump decided haphazardly to at
least claim to be cancelling his meeting
with Putin because of absolute and total
panic I'm talking about just good
old-fashioned fear because the walls are
starting to close in around Trump the
Michael Cohen guilty plea which included
the revelation that actually Trump was
well aware the entire time that Trump
Tower Moscow was being negotiated and so
Trump decided I've got to look strong on
Russia no meeting with Putin because he
took that Ukrainian ship never a
believable explanation but that was the
explanation they gave but then and this
is where the lies are only part of the
problem the first lies are only part of
the problem even though it was announced
that the meeting with Putin was canceled
widespread reports were that actually
Trump and Putin did meet at the g20 in
Argentina and eventually press secretary
Sarah Huckabee Sanders who lies for a
job that's her job she even had no
choice to admit that yeah they did meet
but they called it an informal meeting
which is of course brilliant doublespeak
loudly announced that the meeting has
been cancelled have it anyway but call
it informal as if it's not the meeting
that was planned all along and of course
they just can't tell the full truth
because Sarah Huckabee Sanders said that
they briefly met at the famous and
beautiful Teatro colon and Buenos itis
which I've been to many times a
beautiful facility folks top-notch
sara huckabee sander said it was just a
meeting during that social evening event
at the theater but then we actually
heard the full story from kremlin aide
yuri UChicago said oh actually they had
a sideline meeting during the summit as
well it wasn't just the meeting during
the social evening event and of course
since this was an informal meeting pat
we now know don't know the full extent
of what was discussed sarah huckabee
sander said well they did talk about the
black sea incident involving ukraine but
we won't know anything else that was
discussed it would be more shocking at
this point pat if trump just canceled
the meeting and didn't have it and we
were told the truth like that that would
actually be more surprising given their
penchant for distortion and dishonesty i
agree and if you remember a similar
thing happened last year where they had
like a one-hour secret meeting it was
just the two of them and a russian
interpreter and they weren't telling the
press about it somehow or another they
found out but it didn't look very good i
think it's just an annual performance
review i think that's all this is listen
maybe they met maybe they didn't Trump
could have met with anyone I mean
there's like 7 billion people on this
planet Trump meets with people could
have been anyone could have been Putin
or it could have been some random farmer
from Azerbaijan who knows also by the
way the CIA definitely can't be trusted
to tell us whether they met or not
that's for sure the real reason that the
first explanation the Ukraine one that
they were canceling the meeting because
of what Putin did in Ukraine wasn't
believable from day one because Trump
clearly didn't care about that Trump had
days during which he could have
commented about that and he didn't
comment about Russia's aggression
against Ukraine if that were the real
reason we would have heard from him
sooner he really just has no idea how to
manage any of these situations he's
increasingly isolated he's increasingly
erratic and he's increasingly cornered
and this is what it's causing one of the
day's sponsors is privacy calm slash
Pakman which is a free service that I
myself use really useful in many
different ways takes just a few seconds
to link your debit card to privacy calm
then you can create virtual credit cards
that are linked directly
to your bank account and you use those
virtual credit card numbers to buy
things online which protects your actual
debit card so that it's not spread all
over the Internet and one of the best
things about it is how their mobile app
and browser extensions for Chrome and
Firefox make it really easy to use let's
say for example that I'm signing up for
a david pakman show membership in the
credit card number field I already see
the privacy comm icon I just click it
choose which of my virtual credit cards
I want to use and the credit card number
expiration date and security code are
automatically entered I can put in any
zip code I want and I'm done and if you
try to use my credit card number that
you just saw on the screen it doesn't
matter because I've already deleted that
virtual card and that's the beauty of
privacy comm there are a ton of
advantages to using a free service like
this for example you can sign up for as
many free trials as you want then just
delete the virtual credit card you used
and never worry about getting charged
for it it protects you from getting
hacked it protects you when companies
are hacked which happens all the time it
is all completely free all you have to
do is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
they're giving everyone in our audience
$5 towards your first purchase when you
sign up using that link